[Music]
I woke up this morning uh this is
absolutely true and I did this the same
thing I do every morning first thing I
immediately went for my cell phone just
immediately no yawn no stretch no time
to listen to the birds just right to the
Facebook feed like it's the Sunday Times
like it's urgent I'm like oh oh Karen
from high school is feeling
blessed big
story because God forbid I'm without my
phone for two seconds literally there's
only one place in my house that I am
without my phone and that's the shower
and that's only out of concern for the
phone I would if I could in the future
when we have like digital contact lenses
that are waterproof that connect to our
phones you know I'm going to be in there
just sharing watching Madagascar
like the giraffe's in love with the
hippo but for now I'm without it I'm so
attached to it I'm never too far though
I bring it into the bathroom with me I
bring it in and I put it on the toilet
just so I can keep an eye on my phone
like I'm a parent leaving my toddler in
the car just for a second just for a
second when I run into 7-Eleven just
like stay here pal stay there champ
Champion my little Champion chies Champs
Daddy's going to run at 711 ch ch ch
ch
we all do it is what I'm saying we all
bring our phones everywhere I I recently
went to a concert paid $50 to go to a
concert but I couldn't really enjoy it
because half of the audience had their
cell phones in the air the entire show
just like I got it I'm
recording I got it all recording it
don't worry going to put on YouTube Mage
hits on YouTube going to get some Mage
hits don't worry about it just watch the
concert just watch it your phone doesn't
need to be held up so it can see
too it's bad enough you got guys putting
their girlfriends on their shoulders but
you know at least with her sometimes it
takes a top off you know what I mean
should have said she but said it that
was
weird little little glimpse into how I
see
women sometimes it takes the things
out oh great I'm a sociopath I didn't
even know until this moment and it's not
even just concerts go to anything fun
any sort of fun Gathering a party and I
will show you some dildo who wants to
bring I will show you some dildo who
wants to bring it to a screeching halt
so they can get a group photo I'm okay
with photos but group photos that person
that's like everybody stop everybody
stop everybody stop I got some mergence
Stop Fun stop the fun stop the eating
and the drinking quit making out
everybody gather around quit living I
want to get a photo I want to get a
photo I want to get a photo actually
Carol could you take a photo cuz I want
to be in the photo and you're kind of
new we all love you we all love you but
you're a little bit new you're a little
bit new I'm going to make that call
okay you what are you Annie lieo itz
scrap if you take a group photo at a
party you're literally capturing the
worst moment of the party and it's your
fault why are people always taking
pictures you interrupt everything
they're like I don't want to miss
anything yeah the people who don't want
to miss anything are missing everything
the party to them was just organizing
and snapping things that's not fun that
was a rift line and it didn't really
make
sense the only time I can imagine that
photographs group photos was more
distracting was probably back in the old
days you know with the really old
cameras you know what I mean one of
those where you had to stand still for
five minutes just at some party just
like oh it's a smashing julip Vern and
smashing did you see my uh huge wheeled
bicycle at front yeah that is new oh
somebody somebody wants to do a
photo
you got it you got
[Laughter]
no
you got it you got it oh great great
yeah it's new tonic uh
[Music]
sure